[Music]
in kids only news yes
all parts here adopted submitted by
mother love you wanna love you
adult LEGO fans are claiming
discrimination for being banned from
visiting Legoland without a kids like
Chucky jeepers I can get that accident
hey what are you doing here without a
kid like I kinda [ __ ] lego man actually
pretty cool I'm just upset that there's
no rides for me there's some rides that
are just too small
like what rights do they have there's
not one where you sit down and it like
goes up and down like that but you put
like a yeah I would love to have a
company policy like it like it was like
for Legoland right where it's like your
parents and you got a 15 year old kid
it's like what the hell are you doing
here get the [ __ ] out of here use a
shaving is very early age limit limit
yeah like what I like
oh you're too big you can't like
majority of is for like infants to like
almost five-year-old we're put the
pedophile family and then like it's 40
year old couple with a seven year old
parents and then they're like I'm
bringing my kids to Legoland it's
usually pool yeah drive a Hummer through
but if you're an uncle that's like a
third wheel you know like you're with a
couple but you're alone and you go to
get popcorn and you don't have a kid
because kids with the parents what are
you just point I know that's my kid I
bet a woman can get in I'll just borrow
Isaac so this Legoland is technically a
Legoland Discovery Center and it says
first ever in Australia so it's in
Melbourne what does that mean there's no
rides because it's a Discovery Center so
I'm going to show you touch tank before
you touch that Legos I'm going to show
you guys is quick like about two minute
video that's going to react so just
going to show you what Google's coverage
Center has
[Music]
yeah there's no safer kid it's the first
in its world no no one else can come in
alone : so bored that is dog I'm kind of
jealous I guess we're gonna make a
winner hey Alex for you I I want to go
here double got in space all up in the
glass
[Music]
[Music]
cool
whoa they light up
radical lights in there we got a police
station in there too tight
he'll
oh boy
baby I've cream you had a lot of eyebrow
hair I only want to go cuz they're
telling me I can do cool corporate video
man that loop so this Discovery Center
is aimed specifically for children ages
3 to 11 or [ __ ] yeah you're out are
there two you're [ __ ] it if you're 11
and you got two little siblings like
you're standing outside the park looking
out looking up through the gate three to
eight that's it so that's like the main
target right but they're saying that you
know a lot of these rides and a lot of
the interactive games that they played
mainly for kids so that's why it's not
at all for adults so they're saying it's
weirdly attracting forty five-year-old
single men I mean they're just like
favorite a water just lego fan no why
would I want to tuck in my shirt I like
to wear a fanny and I like to go to
Legoland a lot of you the headline is
that Lego fans are getting mad so
they're just like I'm just a hardcore
lego fan what it would I say you were
crowding in and you're already a
pedophile dude let's get you the hell
out of here yes oh they mean a lot fold
a fol oh they're adult Panda Legos self
subscribe political asylum
they call themselves awful you know what
though I looked up how much my childhood
Lego dreams were they sell them on eBay
and some of them are thousands of
dollars because now they're collectors
items and then they're still in the box
and all that stuff because I always
wanted like the pirate ship and all that
you know the series yeah and in the
medieval one that's just that yeah I
remember really lucky those when I was
oh this should be third this is in a box
the whole time I might be of Toy Story 3
when I just forgot they never got out of
their phone I just had this phase of
like hey now I got a little bit of extra
money
let me just buy all the [ __ ] that I've
always wanted he's been through those
not was a Lego set I told a price and I
was like I didn't think it was going to
be like a couple hundred yeah but it
wasn't it was thousand teens
didn't feel your homelessness I wish I
thank God I got here for a second I was
worried about my brother I was thinkin
he's part awful I mean its first a Lego
then it's the pedophilia but luckily I
didn't make that first step there's a
lot of people angry angry pedophiles are
angry so instead absolutely disgusted to
hear that you will discriminate on
grounds of age Lego is something that is
enjoyed across all ages I personally
have thousands of dollars worth of the
creator and architecture series and it's
clear that many adults without children
will want to experience the attraction
I hope you've done your homework on this
one because I will be making a complaint
to the VCAT if you knock me back on my
ground you one of those guys that spend
thousands of dollars on those
collector's item another one says
extremely disappointed to purchase an
annual pass which is worth about $77 Oh
No at launch where they failed to state
I needed to attend with a child just got
turned away at the preview opening no
phone number or contact for a refund
just lost a lot of this bull they can't
you can't get money back that's
according to that person I was trying to
figure out the father customer service
window you can go talk to you just get
your freaking money back but not if we
go out do it yo what the [ __ ] like that
kind of [ __ ] I feel like he was like
being an [ __ ] or something amazing so
there's last one I'm going to read
absolutely disgraceful having to have a
child to gain entry I grew up with Lego
and you're just a lien aiding a group of
adults who paid lots of money to buy and
play with Legos period discrimination
against age now I'm using I'm going back
to Little Ponies like you know what I
was way more accepted in My Little Pony
community one of our lyft driver was
like all about that money he was talking
about openly yeah you were so proud I
don't want anyone so bad and know that
guys are into My Little Pony oh yeah the
whole thing you can look on Netflix
there's a documentary about brony
what is it like they is just nostalgia
is that a really intimate Pony one issue
and they talk about why and how there's
like a message in each episode that like
is free yeah and how each colony is so
inspirational it's really about
friendship you guys don't get it is it
like Care Bears I remember My Little
Pony I just didn't it was a show that
was tied to it yeah yeah my sister
watched it it was like ponies and they
each yes kind of like Care Bears where
they have a different stamp on their hi
I understand his Ninja Turtles and I was
pretty upset when the new Ninja Turtles
came out because it was not the same I
was like what the [ __ ] is this they're
like on steroids and they're like man
this is not the Ninja Turtles I know
yeah
they lost their like to help bro what
happened to them yeah the alternative
widget I don't know where what happened
to the surfer guys I knew who was the
one that was like really torn Donatello
or Raphael oh yeah he had like the dark
past
right now what's his problem I like
Michelangelo he was like the dumbass
always positive
Leonardo was the he loves pizza dude who
is the red one yeah that's the one I
like oh really
I don't know yeah most girls like them
though yeah he like muscles like the bad
boy we know it was a little [ __ ] dude
he's like yes Jeremy after splinter
discipline Oh [ __ ] knees is a sphere
teach us Pat yeah all the way and
Donatello was a smart one he would never
got her be horribly came home with a -
me cry if they had a turtle world bow be
my [ __ ] but they need to bring it back
to the whole school or you can just make
it happen I never thought of that Julia
maybe that's a good idea
I wish there's people want to complain
it's kind of a bummer because I get it I
get why like you're not trying to be
ageing your model enthusiast you gotta
be you gotta be if you know what it's
like to be an enthusiast and they go hey
you can't come in to the Gucci store
just so you guys know this Discovery
Center does hold in adult-only nights
once a month yeah so at Legoland there's
this place where they made like like Las
Vegas from just Legos or like New York
City and it's this whole crazy display
and it's all the adults there that's
like
JME that's dope and the kids are just
like I want to go on a ride for the
sixth birthday to Legoland
I was like fascinated as the whole town
was like can we call it a ride yeah you
don't care you think about it you're on
the grow you're driving from wherever
and you're in the car the whole way that
you're so excited to go to Legoland
because there's like rides and then you
get there and your parents make you look
at boring structure things like that so
that's so boring
that's why SeaWorld sucked ass always
because and for me I didn't even take
watching the documentary blackfish I was
always like see what was boring I like
SeaWorld because I got like all wet I
got to see in the front like a good
splash I went once and I was like this
is [ __ ] up hope you guys enjoyed that
episode if you guys have any juicy
little Gus of details and you guys wanna
submit it well guess what you can cruise
on over to the description box below
click on the link submit the story and
hopefully we will pick it and talk about
it for more videos click right over here
[Music]